i think something people really need to
be aware of if they're sick
is to get more opinions if you go to the
medical system and you're chronically
ill
every doctor says this is the answer
they don't tell you not to get more
opinions but they kind of infer that
there's no point because
the medical system is one that is not
true
especially if you need surgery go see
like four people i had my ankle
re-replaced a couple of years ago i got
four opinions and each one was so
different
like one guy was like you know we
replaced the whole thing you're screwed
you're going to end up with it amputated
when you're 40.
and he was one of the top guys in the
states and i went to switzerland and got
an opinion and he said
only one component needs to be changed
and you'll be good for the rest of your
life
and that was the guy i went with if
you're looking for physicians or health
professionals
go to the person that says we can help
this isn't forever but if you go to
someone who says this is a chronic
disease you're going
to get worse and worse and worse that's
probably not the person you want
treating you